today's event is not about the history
of email nor about Shiva himself it's
about the future of the post office as
Shiva and I both strongly agree I'm
scarcely alone in believing that this is
a fundamental question the future of the
post
office it's a fundamental question not
only because today's Postal Service
confronts daunting immediate problems as
our Forum will surely demonstrate it's a
fundamental question because the history
of the post office is so intimately and
some including myself would say
gloriously tied to the history of
American
democracy however diminished and
threatened the post office remains an
institution that claims the affection
the loyalty and increasingly alas The
Nostalgia of many of our
citizens the recent announcement for
example of possible Saturday closings
generated a raft of pained articles in
place like the New York Times And The
New Yorker not to mention an ocean of
commentary that appeared in the
blogosphere just over the possibility
that Saturday deliveries might be
curtailed or or or or
stopped one measure then of the cultural
importance of the post office we might
say is its almost Mythic status in our
popular culture in our songs our poems
our novels or visual art our plays our
movies I'm reminded of a movie many you
a great a great financial catastrophe
and one of the on on many people's list
of the 10 worst movies of all time
although not for me because I love the
post office a film some of you may know
Kevin Costner's ridiculous
post-apocalyptic film called The Postman
but I mention it because if you think of
it's based on a science fiction novel
that had been published in the 80s the
film came out in the late 9s it's a very
interesting film from a postal
standpoint because it essentially what
it posits is is that the post office is
the last vestage or remnant of an idea
of democracy and personal autonomy and
in this post-apocalyptic world the
postman's uniform comes to stand for
Freedom it comes to stand for a Civic
Community which has to be reestablished
after a uh uh some kind of typical uh
science fiction apocalypse uh uh the
postman is one of the least interesting
from an artistic standpoint of an an
immense range of artist IC and uh uh uh
uh narrative Expressions that grow out
of and that and that have been animated
by or or or inspired by the realities of
the post office in in in in American
life so as we consider the fate of the
post office today we must I think be
conscious of the fact that all the major
institutions of modern society libraries
universities our systems of Art and
entertainment are all being transformed
by the digital future now
impending one overriding question then
is not the specific details of this or
that Financial rescue package for a
beleaguered employer but the question of
the Civic Democratic principles that
establish the post office will those
values survive in the digital age I hope
that that question will at least hover
over our discourse for the entire
afternoon it's now my pleasure to
introduce the moderator and co-organizer
of this of this event to whom I'm very
grateful for his intelligence and help
in organizing this forum uh Shiva aadar
aadar Dura Aya durai uh he's a lecturer
at MIT in both the department of
biological engineering and comparative
media studies as director of the email
lab he works with the US Postal Service
of the Inspector General exploring ways
to retain postal workers jobs through
the provisioning of email Services his
book the email Revolution is forthcoming
this fall
Shiva thank you David thanks for that
warm
introduction so it's a pleasure to uh
host this forum today and um I I
appreciate um David's comments on
putting why we're hosting this forum
today this is not about me it's really
to talk about the future of the post
office
and it's a very very important question
and I think it's a very personal
question you know I just want to share
an aside when my uh father came here in
1969 uh you know he came here with $75
was the time of the recession and uh the
job that he was promised didn't exist so
he went to the
YMCA and he became very friendly with
the local Postman a guy by the name of
Max uh novic who ended up becoming very
close to my father ended up taking my
father home to his home and when we
first came to the United States we
stayed in the home of a postman so it's
uh so to me the US Postal Service is a
very touching uh part of my personal
life and uh relative to the issue with
mail um how have I been involved in how
how did I get here and how did David and
I end up doing this was um my history
with mail goes back to a long time for
me when I look at mail be it email or
Postal mail I've always seen mail as
something print or digital that gets
processed in a very s simp in a very
similar way
in 78 at the University of Medicine
Dentistry it was an opportunity for me
to look at mail in the electronic form
in '93 I had the same opportunity with
the White House to process mail in in a
similar way to help the White House and
in 97 as I was mentioning to David it
was an opportunity uh to go back to the
US Postal Service and say hey look the
postal service should also look at mail
in both its print and electronic format
and so last year when I heard about the
impending disruption with the Postal
Service
um I reached out and I said look uh the
postal service should again look at both
opportunities print and electronic and
that led to a series of Articles and
finally uh I had the opportunity to meet
David Williams David reached out and he
said yes you know there are people who
are looking at this there are other
opportunities that the Postal Service
needs to look at and it ended up
becoming initially a collegial
relationship and we started to think
about through the email app to host a
series of workshops and look at this and
that ended up with David and I
recognizing that this is a much larger
issue and we needed to have a forum
about this and that led to this so
that's how we got here and uh I want to
encourage everyone to have a lot of fun
at this we have excellent speakers here
and uh the format of this evening's
forum is uh going to be sort of a Hybrid
part where the three speakers will have
the opportunity to present 10 to 12
minutes I will be the time jerk because
we want to make sure we have the
opportunity to get everyone here to
participate um Richard John uh is a
professor at the Columbia School of
Journalism Richard will first present
uh he's a noted historian on the postal
service and Richard is going to give us
an educational run through through the
Postal Service then we're going to go to
Kent Smith who's the manager in the
office of strategic business planning in
the US Postal Service Ken is going to
bring us up to date what is the current
situation and then what is a strategic
plan for the postal service over the
next five years and then David is going
to give his presentation as the
Ombudsman in some ways of the American
people as he Inspector General what
recommendations he's made some of the
new vision he's put forward and that's
that's going to be in a presentation
format after that the speakers will come
up and I'm going to facilitate a
moderated session around four to five
questions hopefully that'll go for 20
minutes and that'll take us to around
620 6 625 and that'll give us hopefully
20 to 40 minutes of all of you to
participate in the discussion and uh in
that participation there are two mics
set up and everything as you notice is
being taped so please come up to the mic
and ask a question please hold the
commentary ask your question then uh
each of the speakers and myself May uh
respond to that so that is a format for
for this evening I'd like to first of
all introduce Richard John from uh
Colombia he's a professor of Journalism
there
[Applause]
Richard
well thanks so much David Shiva for
organizing this and Shiva for the very
gracious uh
introduction uh for many years we've
been uh told that Benjamin Franklin is
the founder of the post office and that
the values and ideals that Benjamin
Franklin exemplified uh have forever
after uh shaped its Destiny and I'm here
tonight to tell you that that just ain't
so that Benjamin Franklin's contribution
to the post office has been much
overrated and that I think in some ways
it distorts our understanding of its
Civic mandate like to propose an
alternative founder the post office the
Revolutionary philosopher Statesman and
Enlightenment philosoph Benjamin Rush
Benjamin Rush in January 1787
articulated something that Benjamin
Franklin never did Civic mandate for the
Post Office and a remarkable address to
the people of the United States for the
purpose of diffusing
knowledge as well as the living
principle of government to every part of
the United States every state city
county Village and Township in the union
should be tied together by means of the
post office this is the true
non-electric wire of government perhaps
a reference to Franklin there it's the
only means of associated with
electricity it's the only means of
conveying heat and light to every
individual in the federal Commonwealth
it should be the constant injunction to
the postmasters to convey newspapers
free of all charge for postage a con
conviction that was shared by George
Washington not ultimately adopted but
newspapers are not only the vehicles of
knowledge and intelligence but the
Sentinels of Liberties our country so
what I'm proposing here is that the
Civic Mandate of the post office is
Broad Dynamic and open-ended and it was
something that Benjamin Franklin could
not have foreseen he dies in 1790 at
just the moment when the Constitution is
being operationalized and it's the
operationalization of the Federal
Constitution that leads to the Civic M
the reinstitutionalization of the Civic
Mandate of the post office that Russia
articulated so brilliantly in
1787 there's no ringing preamble to the
post office Act of 1792 which is the
foundational legislation for this
remarkable institution yet it has three
key Provisions first a rate structure
that provides very low advantageous
rates for the circulation of information
on public affairs newspapers soon
thereafter magazines second development
strategy that gives control of the
extension of the postal Network to
Congress in effect giving it to the
people rather than the executive
hastening its remarkably rapid expansion
expansion of the network beginning in
1792 and third and by no means
incidentally a surveillance St standard
that prohibits the opening of letters
for the purpose of uh for the purpose of
inspection for the purpose of
surveillance so you have a rate
structure development strategy
surveillance standard set
1792 based on enlightenment principles
embodied by Best by Benjamin Rush for if
the people were Sovereign as the
Constitution proclaimed it seemed
indisputable that the government had an
obligation to provide them with regular
broadcasts on public affairs from the
seat of power no longer is access to
information about public affairs a
privilege rather it now became a right
or more precisely a practical necessity
for a government whose legitimacy rested
in the sovereignity of the people the
male declared one lawmaker in the course
of the debate over the post office Act
of 1792 the mail had been established
for no other purpose than the conveyance
of information into every part of the
Union those are two foundational
statements of the Civic Mandate of post
office the Mandate of the federal
government to circulate information was
seldom questioned and only on rare
occasions was it even debated at least
in part this was because contemporaries
presumed that the benefits of the
circulation of information to be not
only political but also economic to
stimulate the desire for
exchange explained the American
political political Economist Francis
wayand in an influential textbook he
published in 1837 to stimulate this
desire for exchange lawmakers had at
their disposal only a limited number of
tools and among the most effective of
these tools was legislation to Foster
the physical means for the dissemination
of knowledge and intelligence through
the establishment of an efficient and
cheap post office system that should
pervade every portion of the country and
bring to Every Man's door all of the
information circulating throughout the
Civilized world it was a system because
of these cross subsidies these cross
subsidies facilitated the lowcost
circulation of newspapers and magazines
throughout the length and breadth of the
country the complete transmission of
intelligence to the most distant Point
reflected a jurist in
1873 was one of the conditions of
civilization for should lawmakers
eliminate these cross subsidies
circulation of newspapers magazines
should lawmakers eliminate these cross
subsidies goodness knows what the future
would hold and here I quote one could
hardly imagine what would be the
condition of National Affairs if the
greater part of our population cut off
from letters and newspapers knew little
more of the Affairs of Washington than
the returning members of Congress chose
to tell them the post office Department
could never be dispensed with was the
one agency of government that came
impartially to Every Man's door there's
that phrase once again the kinds of
information that the post office
Department had a Civic mandate to
circulate expanded repeatedly 1790s the
band was confined primarily to
information on public affairs here we
have uh I'm going to show them rapid
succession three of the first most
notable genre paintings all set in
explicitly set in post offices there's
the male arriving in
1814 there's the mail the news arriving
of the war in Mexico in 1848 notice the
sign indicates post office and there's
the California news 1850 these are our
coffee houses the place you got
information on uh public affairs by 1825
the Mandate embraced information on
market trends and for a period of time
the government actually tried to outpace
private carriers in the circulation of
information concerning the price of
cotton the price of uh wheat and this
principle uh LED Samuel mois to uh
commit himself to trying to sell his
patents to the on the electric Telegraph
to the government it led to a project
that was never consummated uh oh there's
the there's the mail stage which moves
the mail quickly The Early Republic and
my unconsummated project which was the
horsedrawn monor rail was supposed to go
from Washington uh to New Orleans a
favorite of the postal administration of
that time and it led to the uh fast mail
1875 and eventually to the
commitment conviction of a large number
of Americans by no means only radicals
that the government should take over the
electric Telegraph dispossessed Jay
Gould you see him in the background
there Uncle Sam taking over the
Telegraph and grafting it on to the post
office Department with a remarkable
statement of the Civic Mandate of the
institution the best kind of Monopoly
let the people's government Supply the
people's uh
information by 1845 the mandate expanded
to embrace information on personal
matters by 1913 to parcels and also to
the provisioning of a basic level of
postal of savings postal savings PS well
how is the Mandate of the post office
understood today well in recent years
lawmakers have have asserted that the
post office has a universal service
obligation phrase Universal service
obligation for for the historian the
most remarkable fact about this phrase
you Universal service obligation is its
novelty before 2002 the phrase does not
turn up in an electronic keyword search
of the annual reports of the Postmaster
General the related phrase Universal
service is only slightly more venerable
it's first occurrence in a annual report
of the Postmaster General I'm able to
locate occurred in 1990 and the first
time the phrase Universal service
appeared more than once and this time it
occurred twice was in
1995 now the phase invocation of the
phrase Universal service in a postal
context before 1995 is hardly unknown
the phrase appears twice in the
executive summary of tour postal
Excellence a major congressionally
funded study of postal policy that
Lynden Johnson commissioned in
1967 it's a matter of speculation why
the authors of Tor postal Excellence
included this phrase Universal service
in their executive summary one
explanation could be found in the
occupational back ground of the
committee that headed up the commission
the commission included several Business
Leaders who would have been familiar
with the phrase Universal service in the
context of
telecommunications in fact the chair of
the commission Frederick kappal was
himself the recently retired chair of
AT&T a corporation that had used the
phrase Universal service extensively in
its public relations advertising since
the early uh 20th century as we see here
from this Bell System ad harking back to
uh the opening decade of the 20th
century in a recent essay the justly
respected historian of postal policy uh
has proposed defining Universal service
in a postal context as a communication
safety net it seems to me that this is
too narrow for the idea of a safety net
is but one facet of the Civic Mandate of
the post office as it has been
understood much of our
history it presupposes this mandate that
the post office will maintain Ain a
Communications Network for the entire
population that will promote goals that
are included that include but are by no
means confined to the circulation of
information on public affairs to equate
this mandate with a safety net would
have seemed to earlier generations of
lawmakers including the founders to be
unduly narrow the Civic mandate embraced
everyone and not merely those
individuals who might find themselves
marginalized by technological advance in
the means of communication so to
conclude the Mandate of the post office
has embraced at different times a
variety of values of which the most
enduring been openness and
inclusivity openness and inclusivity are
like Universal and service notoriously
hard to Define and almost impossible to
measure with any Precision yet if we
take Russia's 1787 address and the
printed reports of the Congressional
debates over the post office act 1792 is
our proof text it's evident that the
lawmakers who established the post
office presumed that the federal
government had a duty to provide the
entire population with access to
information including information on
public affairs in the 1820s lawmakers
expanded this mandate to embrace
information on market trends in 1845
they expanded it to personal matters
this egalitarian dimension of postal
policy received a particularly forceful
expression in 1917 when postal
administrator Daniel C rooper UND scored
its Civic significance the struggle for
human rights rer declared and here I
quote presupposed free communication on
equal conditions while and here I quote
again progress in the facilities for
such communication had made the post
office a democratic institution so what
I've proposed here is this a Civic
mandate for the Post Office goes back to
the 1790s not quite so far back to
Franklin and that there's a reservoir of
Goodwill that resides in the institution
as a result of this a cvic mandate and
just to as an epilogue this reservoir of
Goodwill I I have my own movie uh to
propose the Miracle on 34th Street uh
1947 in which the key uh plot twist at
the end where we have Santa Claus and
the little girl if you know this movie
the little girl believes in Santa Claus
the world is unforgiving yet you in the
uh penultimate scene we discover the
judge who's buried under mail addressed
to Chris kingle Santa Claus and he
throws out the case against Chris
Kringle because the post office
department has declared that yes there
is a Santa Claus because that's for whom
that mail was addressed and it these
reservoirs of uh Goodwill I think that
as we go forward reservoirs that go back
to the founding of this country are
absolutely essential American
democracies has come to be understood
that we can draw on as we look forward
to an uncertain future thank
[Applause]
you thank you Richard so our next
speaker is Kent Smith and Kent's the
manager of the Strategic uh Planning
Group in the US Postal Service Kent
thank
you
now for many of you are not familiar
with the history and background of the
postal service but many of us who work
there have worked our entire lives there
it's a culture that goes back several
hundred years and many of us have been
there for almost that
long some of most of us in the Postal
Service come up through the ranks I was
a male handler way back when and the
love for the postal service this idea
that there's something more to it than
just our day-to-day jobs is really a
part of who we are and what we are and
this idea that we go everywhere and we
deliver you know to the bottom of the
Grand Canyon dog sleds in Alaska and all
this other kind of stuff it's really a
part of what we live and breathe now I
was asked to talk about you know how we
got to where we are now and uh how we
plan to get out of it and perhaps talk
just a little bit about the Future Okay
um you're all familiar with the news
we've been uh it's been well publicized
that we're facing a financial crisis
there's a couple of reasons behind that
but I want to start with this idea that
the Postal Service even the most recent
version of the Postal Service yes we're
235 plus years of history since 1970
we've undergone at least two major
Transformations that would just Astound
most business school and public policy
students we went from the post office
Department to The Postal Service a a
pure government uh organization with a
cabinet head for a leader to a
self-sufficient Break Even mandate
organization we also went from manual
trans manual handling of almost
everything to a very highly automated
system and we did did that while the
system was in motion it was an
incredible achievement that is kind of
in the background of most people's
Consciousness most people don't realize
what it took to get us successfully
through the last 35 years it was an
incredible amount of organizational
transformation we actually have that in
our DNA as we Face the challenges of
this particular future our challenge is
of course that we've got to do both a
business model change and an operational
change in a shorter period of time than
the 35 years we've we had under Postal
reorganization in a much less forgiving
environment I want to since we are so
much in the background we're taken for
granted in many ways but when you look
at some of these numbers you come to
realize we are
huge and and one of the things that gets
lost in some of the discussions about
the future of the postal service is that
even if we all agree with the assumption
that male volume and revenues will
continue to decline over the next 5 to
10 years in 5 to 10 years we will still
be a huge organization and we will be
the center of an enormous amount of
economic activity in 5 to 10 years we
are still likely to
be Fortune 500 company if we were listed
on the Fortune 500 list we would be the
largest Fleet owner we would have
probably even if we got rid of all the
post offices that anyone would want to
get rid of we would still have more
retail locations than anybody else
so when we talk about the future of the
organization 5 10 years from now we're
talking about the future of a huge
organization that will still be the
center of an enormous amount of economic
activity in the country now we would be
foolish not to understand or not to
admit the future that we face and the
future that we've gone through the
disruption caused by technology and the
whole digital future and email and
everything else social media and all the
other things you kind of consider and in
some ways when we talk about the postal
service we talk about the Postal Service
being an old ancient creeking
organization holding on to the ways of
the path while our customers are coming
to us with iPads and all sorts of other
things like that it's not really the
story now we mostly talk about the
public policy uncertainty we talk about
the pervasive uh technological changes
we don't talk as much about some of the
demographic and social trends The New
Normal of household finances and things
like that let me use a very very brief
example example uh that has nothing to
do with uh electronic disruption but
plays a major role in the volume history
of the Postal Service both going up and
going down most of you are familiar with
the idea of credit cards used to be that
nobody had credit cards you know 20
years ago almost nobody did and then
credit card industry developed this this
whole concept and there was an enormous
amount of mail generated
as we all got two three four five and I
don't know how many I what what the
average household peaked off peaked out
at which was about nine something like
that and then we they started okay no
one was getting any more credit cards so
they fought among each other come to my
credit card come get my points uh my
lower rates whatever and still
generating an enormous amount of mail at
a response rate of 1 to 2%
but it was still the best deal in town
for them now all that male volume came
up reached its peak and started to
decline before and irregardless of
anything having to do with electronic
mail electronic whatever it was just
part of what comes in the mail what
leaves the mail it's part of a cycle
that's gone on for next to forever now
we Face a fairly Grim assessment of our
current future
and at its very basic we know volume is
going down and unfortunately the volume
that's going down is our most profitable
line of business first class
male at the same time we're not
permitted to raise our prices any more
than the rate of inflation in fact even
before that became a legislative
mandate uh as a result of the postal
accountability enhancement act that's
pretty much was our policy not to raise
rates faster than the rate of inflation
and that's pretty much what we did since
1970 even though we were absorbing a
subsidy that had been a quarter of our
budget and we no longer of course
despite all the Miss we no longer accept
public funds we are completely
self-sufficient okay at the same time
our fixed costs this infrastructure
these thousands of post offices and all
the other things that we do continue to
grow even in the recession we had new
delivery points growing at the point of
about a million plus deliveries a year
and we have to deliver to all of them at
the same time we've got a relatively
high cost labor intensive
organization so now this is a tough nut
for any organization of any amount of
skill to handle this was part of the
issue but this we were prepared for
and we made massive changes over the
last decade uh some of the things that
we've done uh parallel anything that was
done with the Auto industry or anything
else we took out more than 120,000
people mostly through
retirement we closed
facilities um we gradually in decreased
facilities from We're showing here 673
to
487 we did that before
people got really excited about it but
we're just talking about now doing a
little bit more in a little bit less
time it's scary but it's something that
we were able to do successfully during
that time we dramatically increased
service quality the American Service
Quality Index an independent assessment
tells us that we are the most
improved uh organization of all the
organizations measured by their
assessment since 199 four that's pretty
prettyy good at the same time we've had
a steady Improvement in customer
satisfaction as we measure it and we've
introduced all sorts of new mail related
products and
services we've done the other kinds of
things that companies facing the kind of
challenges that we do we've reduced
administrative overhead we've closed
administrative offices uh we took out
from from the overhead administrative
positions
um we've Frozen salary all the things
you read about happening in the private
sector we've done and have been doing to
the point for all for almost the last
decade we've been reducing our costs by
about $2 billion doar a year and so
we've been keeping our head above water
quite well thank you uh and in fact even
though until n until 2007 we were
mandated to break even that was our
requirement not to generate a profit but
to break even we were doing fairly well
as you could see here then came the
recession and that made uh item just a
little bit difficult then we had the
unique application of what they call
prefunding
uh we wouldn't be talking about quite
the crisis that we are uh so we've got a
path to profitability we've got a plan
it's fairly detailed we've exposed it to
all sorts of people who private sector
folks who specialize in in restructuring
you know corporate restructuring and
they say yeah you've got the bases
covered you're doing what a responsible
business would
do and this is what we're planning this
is
are our fundamental basis for our
restructuring plan we're going to
preserve the mission mission that uh
good professor talked about we are still
going to maintain our role as a platform
for the development of
Commerce uh our transformation and we
don't want to go back to uh depending on
taxpayers that's just not the place
where uh we want to be and we want to be
fair to employees customers and to other
stat stakeholders so uh like any planner
we can't tell the future but we could
talk about scenarios and I've got four
and I'm going to talk just briefly about
one because it's the most
countercultural and the most challenging
to most of the people who talk about the
postal service and what it is since I'm
here at MIT I'll talk about an ecosystem
of
systems and it's not about the postal
service not just about the postal
service it's about the mailing IND indry
broadly speaking and the technology that
exists around it if you posit the idea
that the Postal Service can continue to
improve in all sorts of interesting ways
but at the same time the value chain the
people who are creating the mail we are
the channel we carry the mail other
people create the content and to succeed
they're going to have to create more
relevant content and all of this is
going to be done at least in part with
digital Technologies being applied to
postal processes to the mail and to the
whole value chain so when we push
ourselves back just a little and think
not so much about we're trying to save
the mail we're not we're trying to help
customers both businesses and consumers
do jobs that are important to them
Clayton christenson's idea from across
the river at Harvard the idea that what
jobs are they hiring the Postal Service
to do
and when you look at our role here the
opportunities to do the kinds of things
that are a little more novel than merely
deliver mail that's not what our
carriers do they help people do things
that are important to them if it was
just snail mail delivering junk they
wouldn't we wouldn't have the kind of
employee commitment that we have they
know that this stuff is important to the
people they deliver to so think about
this kind of future what if take a quick
look at this because my time is almost
gone but I want to show you the
strategies that we have they're sensible
strategies they're balanced um and
they're interdependent we have to
succeed on all of them they're the kind
of stuff that a good business would
do not necessarily the kind of stuff
that we've really focused on the past
with our heritage as a Government
monopoly so the real creativity will
come from this not the creativity of any
of the
silos it will come at the boundaries
between the postal service and the
industry between the industry and the
customers has we come up with new and
creative ways to collaborate to do
things a little bit differently to add
value and so that's my story and I'm
sticking to it thank
you
thanks Kent so we're going to have our
final formal presentation by uh David
Williams who's the Inspector General of
the office of the Inspector General of
the US Postal Service
David thanks sha very
much we stand at the crossroads of a
dangerous Crossroads of the nation's
postal system today that's what I wanted
to talk
about um two things need to be done well
the the the crossroads that we stand at
are that we're losing billions of
dollars and have been losing billions of
dollars and we've been told or not to
modernize the mission of the Postal
Service to become a bug in Amber two
things need to be done to pull out of
this the first is we need to optimize
the postal service and the second is we
need to begin providing adjacent Digital
Services to extend the universal service
obligation to the entire spectrum of
messaging and parcel delivery let me
talk about optimization first we need
fewer post
offices in the right places to meet
supply and
demand and at hours that match modern
lifestyle which which um which we don't
always do we need to recognize that that
both Partners in in relationships are
are working and unavailable during the
day and need the services at night for
our big processing facilities we need to
focus on um volume
throughput and and not exceed that and
lastly for delivery we need to
standardize delivery some people get it
at the door the property line cluster
box boxes we need to move them out in a
standard way so that we can uh run a a
business
operation uh that's probably going to be
the property line and if not practical
for cluster boxes the next thing we need
to do is greatly simplify the way we do
business with customers we have a 1700
page manual that we give customers
including our poor new customers we have
7,600 prices for three products and some
services we people actually hire
middlemen to find out how much it will
cost to put stamps on our products that
has to change the last thing is there
are government raids going on in
progress that inflate
prices uh greatly unfunded mandates
overpayments and overfunding into our
benefit programs that would provide for
billions of dollars of relief 13 billion
immediately billions each year to
provide a lean strong infrastructure for
the traditional male um
service another thing that's you take
sort of a deep breath to keep in mind is
this isn't the first time we've been
we've had this kind of challenge we
could talk about a lot of times but you
remember the paperless that that
happened in your lifetime the paperless
Society within a very short time the
usage of paper had increased by
400% the low cost of printers
distributed Printing and people
mysteriously like paper and they really
like it when they're having a dispute
with someone they don't want them to
hold all of the
cards in its Heyday of the paperless
Society the Postal Service also grew
dramatically and that's the way it was
with the Telegraph and the telephone
broadcast broadcast television and radio
the fax machine their computer were e
supposed to kill male and instead they
entangled and energized one another and
grew dramatically some of these threats
themselves have have uh turned around
the bend and the river of time and
they're gone and the postal service has
again energized and joined new
technologies to become larger than ever
this entire time there was growth
including uh at the when the computer
threatened things it grew to 213 billion
of pieces delivered um annually by the
Postal Service an enormous amount almost
half of the the world's then came the
Big Bang
occurrence the uh the internet and the
elimination of time and distance from
messaging the messaging side of
things the next thing that happened was
that smart devices and social networking
erupted and kind of a secondary
explosion and showers of innovation and
creative destruction rain down on the
world of our
childhoods newspapers magazines
broadcast television music Motion
Pictures bookstores and the poor Postal
Service were all inside the blast radius
of this very changed
World um even relatively new Innovations
didn't make it CDs DVDs
desktops laptops are currently Under
Pressure email began fragmenting into
texts and tweets and
blogs in a in a very
unsettled world of respective respon
respective sort of roles and
interdependencies that's still going on
for a multitasking World on the move
just addicted with faster better and and
it is a better world I I I certainly
don't mind that okay so social
networking and smart devices found each
other and for Generation why the rest of
the world grew very Dim when you could
have conversations and hangout together
uh laptops and email became so five NS
ago and everybody began feeling sorry
for the poor four old fogies of the
Generation
X kids when the dust settles it's a very
unclear what America wants and what they
need for for the road ahead we don't
know a lot of things that that are
currently going on is email killing mail
or tweeting and texting and uh blogging
killing email or is email going to
become the formal mode of of Rapid
Communications and tactial paper and
envelopes the very high end of of that
Continuum going all the way down to
tweeting and and texting for the
moment we can't tell what's going on
very strange artifacts of the past and
sort of edginess are coexisting we see
chatty conversations going on in
correspondence and official reports that
we would not have ever seen we're
getting tweets when we should get emails
emails from we should get letters
condolence tweets for the love of God
the uh
and businesses are responding to emails
as they normally did to mail which is a
real slap in the face to the person that
sent that email they do not expect the
answer in two
weeks future Generations are going to
laugh at this period where we're doing
virtual work in a brick and mortar
environment that we threw the cage door
open and the Animals won't leave the
cage for some reason so how in the world
to follow the kind of quk screw
trajectory of the this age of
communication the cycle time for
everything is being reduced to something
like chaos and
inversely there's a lengthening tale of
digital refugees and technophobes that
that are beginning to drop out of from
far back from the edge where where
others are
existing a very important issue on all
this totally unsettled is who's going to
own and operate this emerging National
infrastructure corporations are
absolutely great we can't do without
them would you like them to be your
government is the next question that we
need to take on and on the road ahead
corporations come and go they go
bankrupt get taken over by other
corporations that don't have any
interest in the previous commitments and
corporations get indicted and there goes
your infrastructure they have conflicts
of
interest issues like net neutrality and
uh common carrier philosophies should be
decided by the public not by a
corporation corporations haven't always
been Trust worthy with people's private
data and
profiling and companies that own the
infrastructure may not be entirely fair
with their competitors who are dependent
on that infrastructure in fact they may
want them to burn in hell the uh far
from somebody that's that's going to be
protective of
them so the traditional
infrastructure has served B the nation
promote democracy enable the information
flow and commerce and assure inclusion
Americans care a lot about inclusion in
a way that maybe the rest of the world
is forging ahead do not when you take a
walk outside one of the tech centers in
China and other emerging countries by
the time you finish that walk you're
beginning to see people
pulling plows being dragged by water
buffalos just a sea of humanity
desperately poor in these glistening
Towers that's not a very American thing
to do and America hasn't tolerated that
in the past the current infrastructur
served the country well for 200 years
but now however the internet introduced
a game Cher time and distance have
disappeared and that's not a bad working
definition of the Postal
Service networking I'm sorry social
networking and the internet have
eliminated time and they've created a
void that hasn't quite been filled by
them or anyone else but in include
security vulnerabilities legal puzzles
loss of confidentially
confidential uh confidentiality of the
message content and a near total
invasion of people's privacy the Postal
Service may need to move Beyond his
traditional role and serve a vital new
role is
um Beyond parcels and mail to begin to
address some of the shortcomings of this
new age but we still we have a very
serious issue Congress has ask us not to
progress as we're as we're weighed
through the digital age globalism
changing workplace and the begin and the
intrusion of of Black Swan occurrences
complex
fast uh actions that are that are
blowing away the risk models that they
no longer
work so we need to decide even if
Congress allows it what is it America
wants and needs from its Postal Service
during the digital age the first thing
we talked about a smaller but Dependable
message and parcel delivery Network
packages don't beam themselves yet do
they still need to get from China to
somebody's house so what could we do the
first thing we could do is develop an
email box in addition to your physical
mailbox that links your physical address
to your electronic address to allow
secure encrypted environment to conduct
business with government and and others
that are financial transaction oriented
we could and that would allow them to
allow you to convert electronic messages
to physical mail pieces and inversely uh
incoming mail could become digital and
become integrated with your email
wouldn't it be great if you could deal
with a single password and pay all your
bills with a single payment and they're
automatically sent out uh a lock box
inside that mailbox would also allow you
with additional security would allow you
to curate archive and transmit all the
documents that are essential to you and
that you're terrified will disappear
medical records safely stored but
shipped in an emergency at your command
and also to curate documents that you
personally care a lot about a global
card could be issued like a the size of
a credit card with an identity chip and
a SIM card option for your telephone to
access postal services egovernment and
to be used as a debit card for digital
cash for obligations that the government
owes
you and allow you could send it to
college students and allow them to
redeem them both post offices and ATMs
and that allow would also allow Secure
Storage when you pull that card out all
the information leaves it with you and
lastly a universal platform through a
web page that allows you to access
postal and E government and other
related commercial applications One-Stop
navigation for all of
government um you can do do a great deal
of business in this one stop digitally
when you can't when you need to close
the business with um in person post
office window services are available to
verify your identification nobody wants
to give a $70 million loan to to someone
in response to an email they're going to
they're going to want that person to
present themselves so the platform
combined with post office window
services are going to provide a lot of
solutions that are currently a problem s
with the
internet um they'll integrate across the
digital divide Security will be provided
much more privacy and government field
structures which are unbelievably costly
could go virtual uh knowing that the
post office window services are
available to close the deal the platform
would need would feature net neutrality
common carrier philosophy low entry
barriers reasonably priced for for
everyone so so let me just wrap it up
the Postal Service mission is to support
Communications and Commercial needs for
Americans the mission is expanded in the
information age of binding the nation
together not don't and it's not just
about paper but I think we could we need
to and must we have a duty to extend the
universal obligation to wherever
Americans need to go and want to go the
Postal Service can help move the country
into the digital age while maintaining
the princip that everyone holds so
important and dear the Constitutional
considerations and the very important
concept of inclusion uh which is uh I
hope the most American of the values
thanks very much
[Applause]
everybody so thank you David so the next
part of the uh event is we're going to
have the three speakers come up and
we're going to uh
move to a moderated uh set of questions
so about three or four questions and
then uh if we depending on how many
questions people have you know we're
going to try to move this forward and
enable people to also engage in the
question answer
process
so I want to begin by
uh when when we set up these questions
we had a number of questions so we we
gave each speaker the opportunity to
sort of submit several and we honed it
down to a finite set so we could get it
in with the hour or within the 30
minutes so the first question we want to
uh pose uh to the speakers here is for
many of us you know the news of the
disruption of the postal service was
quite sudden and shocking if people
think back to last year and was there
any indication that this you know
disruption was coming that's the first
part of the question and if so when and
what were those conditions and why
didn't the Postal Service move faster
for example in uh providing e Services
many of the fign Postal Services have
done uh particularly given the explosive
growth of email if you go look at some
of the data around 96 97 when you see
the growth of AOL and hot mail that's
when you see email volume actually
overtake snail mail volume so the
question is those two parts Kent do you
want to start okay happy to back in
about that time uh the Postal Service
participated in several large multic
cant multi-year studies with the
Institute of the future out in Menlo
Park California and we were working with
several of the major suppliers in the
industry Pitney Bose Seamans and others
as well as a number of foreign posts uh
and we investigated the studies for
about four years so we had pretty
comprehensive view uh across the postal
World about what was happening and what
was the future we developed a set of
scenarios with uh the Consulting Group
at IBM and uh then brought all of postal
senior managers over to Harvard for a
three-day uh uh Deep dive uh with some
of the folks such as Clayton Christenson
and others to get them fully on board
with the idea that this was coming so we
were fully aware of of the implications
and that's when we started that process
that I outlined of uh radically
Transforming Our operations within the
constraints of the uh organization's
ability at the time and that's also when
we started asking for legislative and
Regulatory relief which is a uh somewhat
more complicated
process
David at the time that this at the time
that this struck I I was still a
treasury but I'm I'm it's pretty clear
what
happened the skills at the Postal
Service were primarily involving timely
transport of messaging and Parcels time
and distance disappeared with the
internet um and so we had the wrong we
were in the messaging business but we
were we were had the wrong skill set
also at the postal service and in many
government agencies the desirable skills
were primarily
inertial mail came in 200 billion pieces
and it had to get out that was job
number one so the changes were primarily
incremental that we conceived of another
thing is we were the world leader one
thing about being the world leader of
anything is you can Slough off
reform longer than anybody else
the weaker people have to adapt and
change much more quickly than the world
leaders and you see that at the the
state department and the Department of
Justice they're the last ones to embrace
reforms and changes inside government
because they are so
strong the other Factor was this
happened very fast as a matter of fact
we we're still not sure what happened
and we're still not sure what's coming
next it's it's one of the great exciting
parts of uh of what's going on around us
and lastly it was very difficult to
monetize this new thing and very
difficult to give up
money and and reach out for something
that did not involve money we know we
have to I mean I believe we have to it's
essential that that we it's our duty to
do that but it's difficult to do that
and those were the difficulties if I
could just do one quick followup to that
in the early 2000s the Postal Service
had a number of electronic
experiments uh we had Ecom the successor
to ma gram the successor to the telegram
we had an eill pay service we had uh um
a number of other services that were
hybrid or electronic there were a couple
of things going on at the time one uh we
were a break even organization so that
me we didn't have a whole lot of extra
Capital to spend on these kind of things
to
uh a lot of people were trying a lot of
things during the time and that was
the.com bust as you recall and uh there
was a lot of skepticism and also some
fear about the postal services entry
into that particular Market at the same
time um we were just beginning our
process of real Improvement in quality
and a lot of people said the postal
service should stick to its knitting and
improve the quality of its core male
service
before getting uh into some of this
other
stuff Richard do you have any comments
on some of the transformation from you
know these
different the E Services piece from
transformation why the Postal Service
you know some of the impediments on
going from one format to another at
least exploring that from a historical
perspective well the biggest crisis of
the post office confronted in its
history was in the 1840s and we've
forgotten about that one when as much as
uh 13 2/3 of male Revenue disappeared
almost overnight and when it looked like
the situation was truly dire uh
lawmakers jumped to attention and uh
strengthened the uh Monopoly provisions
of the institution and uh without having
followed the events and anything like
the detail of my colleagues my guess is
is that uh lawmakers might do the same
today
uh and I think part of the problem is
we've forgotten that the post office has
confronted a number of really rough
patches for much of its history it has
run an annual deficit yet that has not
been a public issue and that uh it was
interesting to comment going to an
electronic
future um old media tends not to
disappear when New Media emerges uh and
there may still be particularly with the
idea of of linking electronic with a
print and uh Parcels there may be a lot
of opportunities there that we haven't a
guessed at but did did I suspect the
institution was in for rough water uh I
don't see how any institution that
operates under the kind of constraints
that the post office does regarding the
Regulatory Commission and Congress could
do a better job than it's
done so it's not a surprise
anyone else want to add
anything um I think one of the other
questions that uh that relates to this
is as many people know there's a huge
opportunity many large private companies
since 93 have been looking at which is a
small business Market if you even go
look at online companies you know it's
the biggest nut to crack I mean when I
was running several of my companies uh
echomail you know IBM large companies
were very very interested in how do you
go get those 10 million small businesses
to sell something to them it's called
the SMB Market or some people call it
the vsnb very small business market and
some people look at that as What's
called the last smile you want to have
feet on the street and it's very very
expensive from a a sales perspective to
get feet on the street so the question
around that is you know the US Postal
Service in many ways has this last smile
they have uh you know a lot of people on
the street everyone uh sees people at
their door you know their businesses Etc
so the question is um given that this
advantage that the US Postal Service has
um which many private companies actually
seek is the Postal Service exploiting
this last mile advantage and if so what
are the ways that it has exploited and
what are the ways it plans to exploit
it it's a great question and I'll take a
shot at it um one of the things that did
come out of this 2005 Deep dive that we
took all our officers to was the idea of
The Last Mile and in this particular
case one of the most immediate outgrowth
was uh forming Partnerships or Ventures
with our competitors UPS and FedEx for
example both in the international market
and uh here in the domestic Market where
an awful lot of the uh packages
originally given to UPS or FedEx but
destined for the Home Market or the very
small business Market uh is given to the
postal service for last mile delivery
that also has
sustainability uh implications as well
since there's one truck going down the
neighborhood rather than many so this is
one example of leveraging The Last Mile
the idea that our letter carriers are a
unique National resource that we have
only just begun to figure out to how to
really partner with in uh our operations
and reaching small businesses we've had
tremendous uh help from the National
Association of letter carriers and from
others in uh um reaching out to small
businesses and homebased businesses
through that particular
resource Richard would you like
to you know the last mile issue is one
that throughout our history has been
extremely important for all businesses
sustaining
Innovation and it's one reason I think
that it's very difficult for the future
of the post office to become a political
question because the sorts of folks that
are today dependent on post office for
their business operations and they you
read the stories in the Press they tend
to know their postmaster very well they
they tend to be intimately connected
with it um arities um this is a
formidable potential political force
that's hard to Peg politically so I
think that it is a resource and it's
heartening that the post office is uh
taking advantage of
it let me use a a specific example if
you will at one point an outfit called
Netflix was a very small uh business and
they were challenging the established uh
business model of DVDs reyolds movie
Reynolds and uh they had the unique idea
of using the mail to do so and they were
enormously successful uh they're in the
process of of changing their business
model right now but still uh they did
nothing more than what JC Pennies and
Montgomery Wards and Sears and other
people have done throughout our history
postal service is a platform much like
apple if you look at it that way for
entrepreneur rurs to figure out new ways
to use the veil for new applications to
do new things and we have been passive
recipients of their Innovation over time
one of the biggest differences that
David points out is that you know the
world has changed and uh we can't we
have to be more collaborative with the
industry in opening ourselves up and
working identifying with new businesses
the entrepreneur the entrepreneurs the
innovators to generate this kind of
thing I think we're um we're well into
the digital age there's a lot of
questions hanging over it but we're we
know it we're on the edge I believe of a
a global logistics
Revolution and a lot of enormous things
are occurring
simultaneously one of which is sort of
the death of the middleman the we saw
all these other casualties a casualty of
that one is going to be that they'll
they'll all be gone and that they too
will leave a void that we haven't
filled manufacturers some of the small
manufacturers all over the world are
sending products directly to people's
home
now rather than through rather than
through Sears or through some other
company they're going directly to
people's residences that's a huge change
and it creates a demand for a
an emerging Global Logistics
grid which will have absolutely no
meaning without an effective Last Mile
to take that from those hubs and spokes
down to people's residences are the only
thing that's going to allow this
revolution to occur the postal service
today owns that last
mile
um in it it lives or dies based on the
contribution of each delivery
point so what's needed in order to allow
that vital link to
survive is for the contribution at each
delivery point at each
mailbox to contribute enough to keep it
alive to allow us to to deliver to all
the homes um so the Postal Service needs
to increase that they need to become
involved in delivery on
steroids they're already involved in a
lot of coopertition
with UPS and FedEx and the DHL and the
other parcel delivery people to provide
that last mile service that's not a
popular role and I think people are glad
to combine with us there are also a lot
of other things delivered to homes that
the postal service should be keenly
aware of I think we're also getting to
the point where we can't afford to have
multi-ton trucks rolling through every
neighborhood in the United States hour
after hour after hour for the for the
sake of a greening of America a single
delivery operation through those
neighborhoods would be safer and much
cleaner
um and I I think also there are other
opportunities and we alluded to some of
them some of them are attaching sensors
to the to the trucks to allow people to
to allow the FCC to understand is there
a is there a dead spot there as far as
broadband and if there are if there is
let's do something about it let's
address it this is the only group that
goes everywhere every day and it's the
only group that collect
important um information that's needed
to uh to make America and a great place
and citizens safe and content yeah I
mean it just seems like there's a
tremendous amount of use of those feet
on the street that uh we take for
granted and it's so I think it's an
important area to look at I think um
follow up to some of the uh areas
Richard brought up earlier was you know
there's been the Mandate of the post
office has really expanded in several
significant ways in the past and um the
question is you know what circumstances
really gave rise to this expansion and
what lessons you know might it be for
the postal administrators Richard you
want to start with that yeah the partial
delivery is a really interesting case
study because middlemen May well be
disappearing but much of our history
they were quite powerful and they worked
very closely with the non-postal
carriers to prevent the post office for
example from getting into parcel
delivery we were one of the last
industrialized countries to get into
parcel delivery which we did in 19 uh 13
and that raises the larger question of
who the post office bumps up against
when the post office moves into uh into
new uh areas and certainly uh in the
1840s
post office bumped up against private uh
mail delivery carriers including
companies that we now know of as Wells
Fargo there was very little opposition
to the post office pushing them out of
the business middleman 1880s 90s more
successful government was unable to take
over uh the Telegraph and there've been
initiatives you know better than I do
going back decades to get the government
into electronic mail but there are a
powerful uh interest groups that do not
want the post office to expand uh not
because they think the post office will
fail but because they think the post
office will succeed um and it seems to
me that that needs to be a part of any
political Calculus if we're thinking
about a going ahead to these new uh New
Opportunities postal savings was an
initiative uh that was very successful
not largely forgotten largely immigrant
population uh groups who would not have
invested in a uh non-government Savings
Bank invested with our uh post office
for decades and that need for that was
felt to diminished but there was fierce
opposition to that uh initiative early
on so I just the caution is I see the
opportunities and I I want to recognize
also that there
are historical precedent for a lot of
push back and that push back gets
manifested through Congress which places
all kinds of constraints on post office
which I think is an issue that from a
historical perspective perhaps Demands a
little more attention perhaps more
polite po administrators have been uh
willing to uh willing to
express Kent I think you want to jump on
something there oh I'd love to but maybe
I
shouldn't it's okay do you want to
comment up well yes as it
been um when I uh put that one chart up
there that showed the three uh three
systems if you will uh the creative
industry uh the postal service and of
course the ultimate consumers the
households uh we're already seeing the
change in the households of course in
their attitudes and behaviors and we're
re responding to that at the same time
the established industry what the
community that we call the mailing
industry will have to face the need to
change just as much as the postal
service will and
um I don't use that uh that one graphic
ill advisedly the one that showed the
printers uh still trying to maintain
their tradition uh with the old style
printing press when their customers are
coming to them with the iPad that was
actually taken from a study done by the
printing industry of America where they
were outlining the dramatic need for
change in their industry so the idea
that the postal service has to do the
change but somehow the mailing industry
doesn't uh means that neither of us are
likely to succeed and what we're seeing
is very frequently the
established uh the long established
participants in the industry uh and
they've been around
for 100 years or so um not willing to to
change quite as much as many of the
entrepreneurs who come in and say we'd
love to work directly with you to do
these changes and so when we see the uh
um Netflix the Amazon the ebays these
are new entrance into the market they
didn't exist they're not part of the
established industry but as a result new
services and products are created that
benefit both the larger mailing industry
as well as the Postal Service and most
especially the consumers David do you
have a any anything to add that and
actually as you're answering that David
maybe you could also address this other
issue and others could add to that you
know the postal service has never uh you
know the deficit issue has never been a
major issue and and you know now it's
being brought up as a major issue so I
wanted to also follow upon that you know
the fact the Postal Service loses money
or it's in deficit and and you know why
is it now become a major issue okay
the the big changes in the Postal
Service were the movement from post
office delivery to Door delivery the
extension to rural delivery to the rural
parts of America which helped close the
gap between the way people lived outside
the cities and inside the cities
automation U Machinery that that that
sorts mail down to the order this the
route sequence the order of the houses
come uh the beginning
providing money orders for the unbanked
and now digital cash for the unbanked I
hope beginning to provide e-government
services passport services through the
the post offices those were the changes
and all of those came as a result of the
presentation of a need and the Postal
Service being agile and opportunistic
enough and and high sense of Duty to the
public to reach out and embrace those
those new needs with new change I think
I think those are the essential
characteristics that the Postal Service
needs we owe it to you to have zero
tolerance for bloat lean agile um open
to
change the reason the the reason that a
lot of the financial stress began was
the Congress was concerned that an
aspect of any government agency is that
it in in the absence of efficient market
forces which it will never have because
they have Appropriations
there is a there is a tendency for
government to bloat and so this CPI
control was placed on top of the Postal
Service as a surrogate for efficient
market forces to make sure that we
constantly move toward leanness that was
a great
idea it unfortunately it was it was
instituted at the very moment of the
digital Revolution and so a Kind of
Perfect Storm struck the Postal Service
of the economic downturn the digital a
age and this new imposition of CPI but I
believe in it I I believe that some
control is needed and some surrogate for
efficient market forces is a good thing
so I I can't be against I I suppose I'm
one part of the 10% that still has some
affection toward
Congress but I I believe that in this
action it was intended to do a good
thing and it was intended to to look out
for the well-being of the citizens I add
something to that
um one of the reasons why the issue of
our
deficits uh is is so visible right now
is one it's part of the larger National
conversation about deficits and most
people conflate the postal deficit with
uh the government deficit as if they
were some sort of direct correlation and
there's not but in our particular case
uh and the Inspector General was
particularly good at pointing out about
the nature of our contribution to some
of our our pension for overfunding the
pension overfunding the uh some of the
other requirements that were put on it
but ultimately over the last year or two
became a question of cash flow we've
always been able to manage the cash flow
even though we had a we were running a
deficit but we've got uh a limit on the
amount that we could borrow uh and that
limit was set way back in 1970 given the
size of the organization so now we're
bumping up against the top of that
deficit of that borrowing limitation and
of course we can't go to the private
market for Capital and even if we could
it's a bad time for that kind of
activity so uh you know that's kind of a
rock and a hard place is one of the
reasons why the idea of the the postal
deficit there's a as you said a variety
of Perfect Storm kind of thing for why
it the deficit itself is an issue
Richard do you have any other things to
add just that it's a it's never been a
political issue in our history the post
office is running a deficit um and it
has run a deficit uh most years between
the 1830s and the 1960s so the idea that
the institution would break even is a uh
is a relatively new one and that it has
come with a number of obligations on the
institution some of which have been
discussed that do increase cost so it it
gives the postal administrators very
little limited uh limited
flexibility thank you so I think many of
these questions you know I think it
gives hopefully the audience an
understanding of sort of the
infrastructure issues a budgetary issu
some of these Logistics issues I want to
sort of take the this last question
before we open it up the audience to a
different issue on the Civic function I
think all the speakers you have alluded
to this today when um uh uh there are a
set of laws in J jurist prudence and
maybe you can address that that protect
our mail when we when when I send mail
to David or anyone here there's a set of
laws that protect mail tampering when it
comes to email for example when we sign
up for these free email Services be it
you know Gmail Yahoo Hotmail you know
there's a big double quote around that
free um we give away something which is
our privacy these companies open our
email they can read it they can process
it and it's openly in those privacy
statements
um and the question
is as Citizens I mean it's a question
everyone I think should think about but
as a Civic function that the postal
system was set up for uh when we look
back at that 97 period when email did
take over you know standard mail why
isn't the Postal Service offering us a
protected email service that ensures and
and drives us towards this process of
the body of law that exists for me mail
can hopefully be appended in some ways
to protect our email because uh this is
something I think is becoming
disconcerting to more and more people
the fact that a Gmail or a Facebook
essentially controls all of our
communication and there is no civic
responsibility they have to some of what
you just said David as corporations come
and go so I'd like to get your thoughts
on this from the USPS perspective and
also from the historical perspective and
then before we go to open it
up I think the both service and the
nation need to keep in mind that its
role is not an end it it's intended to
be a means it's intended to enable and
make things better not to compete and
take
over um so that's one thing I would want
to put on the table I I I think that
that would be wrongful for us to take
over and try to compete having said that
I do think something has to be
done if the country is going to keep up
with the other nations that are moving
around found us and toward us and past
us to address some of the weaknesses of
the the digital age and to provide a
national infrastructure supporting that
to address security we need a secure
platform to to do Financial transactions
the contents of those messages have got
to be confidential and identities have
got to be kept private I I think that's
what the national infrastructure owes
the people of the United States and and
that's our proper role not to become one
more Gmail but to make the digital age
better and address its
shortcomings
Richard well there it's an interesting
question historically speaking as a
historian uh the inviability of the mail
was written into federal law in 1792 and
the best that were able to determine the
legislative record the founders several
of them Jefferson Jay um Adams had had
all served as diplomats in Europe and
they were well aware of the uh
pervasiveness of uh breaches of
surveillance it was taken for granted
that diplomats mail would be routinely
read uh and the therefore they were
committed to establishing a surveillance
standard that was really very well very
rigorous so that in fact it was
impossible to open letters or it was
illegal to open letters it was possible
to do it legally uh for many many
decades and this did not prevent certain
States from
barring uh entire classes of material
from going through the mail the greatest
peacetime violation of civil liberties
involved the post office suppression of
abolitionist literature and then in the
post Civil War decades it's an
interesting question of the relationship
between the government and private
corporations in providing security for
telegraphic dispatches Western Union is
the leading telegraphic uh Network
provider uh was very vexed at the
government for violating these secrecy
of uh T telegraphic dispatches because
of what they called these Dragnet
subpoenas at times of political
excitement and I think that there is
going to be concern today um about the
possibility that the government could
use communication facilities if it
develops an internet capability in order
to spy on the citizens and this was the
great concern in the 1870s a body of law
developed to uh protect telegraphic
dispatches so I think the larger issue
is we need a body of law to protect the
security of digital information that
body of law does not exist today and
there's no reason we should assume that
uh corporations on their own are going
to provide that body of Law and we're
kidding ourselves if we think they will
uh whether the post office will be the
be all and endall um is an interesting
is an interesting question but I think
the need is real and by drawing
attention to it uh we can draw on our
own Civic uh Heritage where these
concerns have been with us right from
the beginning it's a very powerful good
point I I I don't think we have any
basis to trust Corporate America or the
government we need the rule of
law and the rule of law is something of
course that we took very take very
serious viously in the realm of uh male
security I mean um The pyman Institute
which measure this kind of thing is
rated the Postal Service as the most
trusted government um organization in
government when it comes to uh privacy
and and uh personal identity and uh
within the uh corporate world I think
the rate US among the top five and we've
backed that up Through the Ages with the
the help of our friends in the postal
inspection service to the point of of if
you remember the the famous scenes in in
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid after
they had robbed the mail the train uh
and were trying to escape the posi they
wondered who were those guys those were
the postal
inspectors yeah you did anecdote you in
the 19th century when someone was
robbing a store they'd often make it
clear that they didn't enter the part of
the store that included at the post
office so they wouldn't get incur the
Wrath of the post office
inspectors as as a followup I mean when
Arab Spring took place in Egypt there
was a moment where vone essentially
struck a deal with the government and
they turned off text messaging people
remember that scene if there's an Arab
Spring here the United
States and the you know and the Googles
Etc running it similar situation can
occur so to you from a Civic function
standpoint is it not the responsibility
of the is of the Postal Service I know
that no one should own it but is doesn't
the Postal Service have the probably the
clearest path to protect our interest as
Citizens um just a side comment on that
because it is very relevant we have this
plan of course to uh close
consolidate uh many of our operating
plants uh we've been in negotiations
with many jurisdictions especially on
the west coast where they're very
heavily into vote by mail and as a
result uh we are delaying the
implementation of some of our
consolidations because we are not to
disrupt uh the the primary elections
where they depend on vote by mail
similarly uh we're suspending our uh
consolidation operations not only come
you know October November not only
because it's peak season but it's also
the uh president presidential elections
and we don't want to disrupt the
political mail at all okay thanks Ken so
what we'd like to do is um unless anyone
else has comments I'd like to open this
up to the audience there are two
microphones on each side and uh since
this is being taped if you'd like to ask
a question if you could come up to the
mic um ask your question as succinctly
as
possible hi um I'm a little bit confused
about what it really means to have the
Postal Service you know in the email
service um in in a physical mail you put
a piece of mail in a mailbox or hand it
to a US government employee and you have
sort of endtoend delivery
responsibility um in email if say I'm
using Gmail my
email packets first start um um on
Comcast then go through three or four
other private companies until they
arrive at um you know the Gmail server
now all of these are private companies
um all of them can to one extent or
another um you know interfere with you
know privacy
security um or you know start filtering
on net neutrality
means what part of that business are you
envisioning the postal service and I
mean are you going to be the you know
the last mile um you know to my house in
terms of networking to you know
connectivity or you just going to run
you know another mail server that will
be subject to you know corporate
constraints um around the edges great
excellent question very very good
question actually the United
States is bringing up the rear end of
the parade on this one Mo a number
number of nations Postal Services World
post now provide Digital Services em in
an email
box um and it works in a variety of ways
but
primarily but but but one of the
functions that primarily delivers is the
ability to
um conduct government business inside
inside a secure environment it's
encrypted and it is its own by the the
um the world
posts it it's not the kind of investment
that U that you need for a mail it's a
much smaller investment but its
intention is not to replace Gmail or the
last four customers of AOL or whoever is
still in the business but is to provide
a channel for secure
transactions um confidentiality of the
contents under penalty of
law and uh privacy of of of identity so
so it's meant to run in parallel but
secure but I'm confused about this the
whole network is owned by the post that
the question speaks to you send a
message electronically it's going to go
through a number of different servers so
in other words the government owns the
entire
backbone my under my understanding is
that there's a there are two models and
there is a model in which in which um um
it does run through the the uh the
internet and there there are
vulnerabilities along the internet that
are meant to be addressed by encryption
and and other
techniques but it is but the rule of law
does extend to those links because that
was the the larger Point speaking
historically that for much of our
history the post office relied on non-
government carriers the airline industry
for example got a major booth Boost from
mail contracts there were not government
planes they were uh non-government
planes the stage coach industry got a
huge boast in the government but there
was a rule of law and and Mark Twain
once called it that sacred governmental
thing the sort of the mail sack that
made a difference and that it seemed to
me to be the more realistic model than
the post office actually building its
own backbone I would say among the
larger countries that that's the case MH
and in the physical side you you are
correct the that
um uh UPS and FedEx move some of our
mail as just as we provide the last mile
uh Airlines trains trucks but the rule
of law extends to them when they violate
the law they they come under federal
investigation right and I would say that
that principle that federal government
will investigate has been quite
important historically in ensuring that
the male will be secure so so David are
you saying that the rule of law even if
it uses private network still will
prevail within within that that's what
we want yes well that's what that's that
is what we have with regard to uh
current with regard to the current so
this would so that would be instructive
and suggestive of the model that we're
imagining and El yes I think the
overriding model is that uh the fosil
service will operate through Partners in
in most of this uh you know whatever the
technology whatever the model there
various different for and postal models
that that exist out there but you know
when you stop and think that virtually
everything every mass mailing every bill
or statement every document is now
generated digitally on some computer
somewhere that uh even if this is
transmitted to The Postal Service
through our acceptance process for major
your mailers it's it's done more and
more
electronically uh you know just in just
at a very minimum to reduce paperwork
and and increase efficiency and then
there's the delivery kind of services
where for example if you get uh
something in a post office box and you
rent a post office box that we would
notify you digitally that those arrive
so um you know it's hard to I mean it's
very easy to limit the potential
applications of the digital hybrid world
to The Postal model any different number
any number of different ways that it
could evolve but it's a it is a very
good question because the the the the
Mandate of the government to provide a
secure channel is very well established
and it would seem to me that that's
significantly different from the
existing mandate for any of the uh
existing as a followup to that you know
from from a some of my colleagues at MIT
have talked about this there's some new
local area Network Technology you know
yaax type routers for example that the
Postal Service technically could put up
in local in their actual real estate
that you could you could build a local
network independent of the backbone so
in some ways the backbone providers or
maybe connected as necessary so local
communities can essentially use a postal
service as their provider for not from
to your point you know from the time the
mail leaves and arrives let's say even
in a local neighborhood it's going
through this trusted brand of the postal
service is this something the postal
servic has looked at as providing that
service you know that Civic function
extending that Civic function to the
local area it's certainly something that
we have been looking at yes yeah and and
I've heard it discussed too and also by
some of our customers asking if Aerials
on
our U
31,000 post offices and Facilities
couldn't almost provide a Wi-Fi umbrella
infrastructure is there to provide a
public network independent of the large
Telos and independent of you know the
mail providers William you had a
question
right follow I mean the whole notion of
the digital divide I mean is sort of the
larger um you know aspect of you know
Network neutrality I mean there's you
know it's one thing for packets to be
transmitted neutrally it's another thing
for cost to you know keep people off the
network and I mean the post office
mission to you know make
communication available I mean seems
there seems to be a fit
here yeah thank
you
William uh just a quick two-part
contextual question um in the history of
the post office that you sketched I
heard hints of a American exceptionalism
argument in a way uh and maybe that's
about the Privacy issue I don't know but
certainly in that it's rooted in the
Enlightenment and in that much of Europe
also develops a postal system kind of in
parallel with ours what I'm curious
about there is the fact that in much of
Europe there's a PTT a post Telephone
and Telegraph are aligned in the US that
never really happened so that's tells me
it's already starting in the 1830s 1840s
for the division of the teleg and
telephone 1870s so I'm curious about why
we departed second part comes to the
Future and where are you looking for
your best cases are there postal systems
out there Finland or Denmark or
somewhere that you know might just be a
fluke of of of the geographical setting
of a country but I'm curious about where
you're looking for your best practices
thanks the exceptionalism question the
United States in the 19th century was
distinctive Alexis D toille famously uh
expressed astonishment at the number of
post offices in the United States
compared to the number of post offices
in France and the the Michigan the
Frontiersman was reading the same news
as the New Yorker and that is not
something that was going to happen at
that time in France that's because the
control over the institution the
expansion of the network was vested in
Congress which was close to the
citizenry and the fiscal mandate for the
post office which remained extremely
important in Britain and France along
with the National Security Dimension was
much less important by 1800 the fiscal
mandate uh had EV had essentially been
abandoned the only reason for the
institution to break even was to prevent
the kind of problems that David spoke
about that if you have no constraint at
all oh my gosh they're going to just
spend money up the Wazoo so the it was
distinctive we had many more post
offices we have many more
newspapers toille got that wrong he
thought we had so many newspapers
because we had federal system of
government decentralization but in fact
we now know we had so many newspapers
because we had massive subsidies for
newspapers why so that's the first part
of it yes the United States is
distinctive um fiscally you're not
raising money and there isn't the
security Obsession which there was say
in France now what happens in the middle
of the century well Samuel Moore
certainly wanted the government to take
over the telegraph he he given patent
rights by the government then he wanted
to sell the patent rights right back to
Congress which is nice work if you can
get it and Congress demurred and so we
developed uh this principle that I call
Market segmentation that we New Media
are not permitted to take over old media
so to go back to Franklin newspapers
didn't take over the post office the
post office didn't take over the
telegraph the telegraph didn't take over
the telephone the telephone didn't take
over radio all of those divides are
politically mediated they're not due to
technology they're not due to economics
they're due to politics and I call
Market segmentation and the presumption
that we should keep these divisions
radioactive 1927 is a very good example
which keeps AT&T out of radio um and
that may well be a principle we want to
think about uh in the future we think
about Google and Facebook and these
other behas of our of our own day so
those are two ways in which the United
States experience is different we don't
get the pay
because of that um and in I think the
fact we don't have a pay T helps explain
the remarkable creativity of our
telephone system uh in the 20th century
I think that's worth um I think that's
worth word for it yeah David to Williams
question have you and Kent looked at
other best business practices you know
yeah actually there's been an extensive
look we we really don't have to go that
far to find the best practices because
most of the world posts are using us
technology firms as their partners and
advisors and
enablers uh but but if you were to to
look internationally certainly Deutsche
Post is a very interesting one to watch
they're doing fascinating sort of
groundbreaking work in the Scandinavian
countries New Zealand's always um on the
edge and fun to watch uh Israeli post
has gone a slightly different way and
it's it's a very good path that that
they've selected there's a there's is
sort of strictly government business you
you have your other um email accounts
for other matters and other other mail e
e mailboxes but that one is Walled off
for your work confidential work with the
government can't you have yeah we
cooperate with the uh um upu the
universal Postal Union in
Switzerland uh and they track what
everybody is doing and it's surprising
how Innovative some of the the very um
smaller post offices and less developed
countries are doing because they're Lea
frogging they can't afford the kind of
infrastructure that we've developed here
we also work with many of the world's
most developed posts through an
organization called the international
postal Corporation in
Belgium um and uh keep track of each
other and and what we're doing so
between that between I mean we we're
tracking everything that everybody has
donees does has the postal world has
become both more collaborative and
competitive as you remember
DHL Deutsche Post tried to invade the
United States uh in with their just in
the package market and of course between
uh UPS and FedEx and Postal Service they
had their buts kicked and rolled back to
to Germany but um you know so it's it's
a very interesting world and we're all
tracking each other so so who's rated
number one in the world as opposed to
nobody really has the system model okay
um it depends on there was a recent
study from the Oxford strategic group
out of England that rated the G20 postal
company or Postal operations and they
rated the US Postal Services as number
one but you have to look at their
criteria they looked at sustainability
they looked at productivity they looked
at uh uh quality and several other
things and that rolled us up to number
one their criteria did not include
Financial viability which uh if they had
included would have put us somewhat
where below doche post and and Swit spos
and a couple of others the little
countries are really you have to be
careful because they're not always
scalable things that that are working in
Singapore New Zealand just can't work in
a huge place like this but they they are
often times at the edge of innovation
they've they've leapt over everybody
else's mistakes and now they're at the
very Leading Edge I I was in South
Africa fairly recently and certainly saw
that that's what they did they they just
didn't have enough money to do a
horrible job and so they didn't do one
and that's thanks let's let's take we
have a question over here gentleman's
been patiently waiting
yeah it's not surprising with for this
place to uh have a lot of questions of
discussion on new things in
communication and so on but um it isn't
that easy for somebody without much
money to pay $200 to $400 for a computer
and 20 to $50 a month to turn it on and
get his email so I think you're in
business for a long
time secondly uh you haven't heard many
complaints against the post office here
it's always been variations on a theme
and so on I think people are pretty
happy with the post office in general
there's no need for
apologies but you've got the current
problem of
finances and in this country we tend to
um be good to everybody if we
can and so what's happened in Washington
we have a debt where the interest every
day is one trillion sorry1 billion
dollar and not
changing um
you take something like a toll taker on
the Mass Turnpike over here 79 to
$90,000 a year so what's can you get to
the question yes yeah a slide up here
said 80% of the cost of the post office
was in
labor so two specific questions I have
heard that
um you pay $100,000 or more for
certain convenience stores to maintain a
post office is that true or not true
second question what are retirement
benefits for people retiring from the
post
office okay um to the two questions
first uh going back to the ancient
history that you talked about when there
was not a post office we often made
arrangements what we call Community post
offices or whatever to have somewhere in
the back room and there was a
little bars in a little corner and a few
Post Office boxes and there was an
arrangement for them to provide the
retail services right uh we have been
doing that for our virtually our entire
history where we work to extend our
reach where there is community demand
and most recently when we talked about
uh perhaps closing some rural post
offices of offering uh those same kind
of services has kind of a franchise if
you will in rural locations we call them
now uh Village Post Offices but the idea
that we would remove postal uh employees
in in this particular case and have it
done under contract now the size of the
contract of course would depend on the
level of business activity
expected that's always been uh pretty
much the pattern what is that level that
you pay um it depends on the size and
the area of the post office uh I I
couldn't really tell you that I'm I'm
those are that's a level of detail down
below my range um for the second
question as far as Retirement um it's
fairly standard government retire
federal government retirement uh we're
mandated by law to be comparable to the
the private sector and uh our ranges for
for many of our uh employees they're
unionized and uh uh subject to
negotiation but the retirement package
is fairly similar to the rest of
government so what is that number
roughly um I could not give you a a
number for the average employee we've
got uh four 500,000 employees I couldn't
tell you what the the the range of the
way from the Postmaster General down to
a letter carrier so so large that the
average would be some would be not a
meaningful number if I knew it I think
um we we talked about this perfect storm
the imposition of CPI and the economic
downturn and the digital Onslaught it
came very swiftly and so Revenue dropped
where it's still huge but it dropped
suddenly it always takes there's always
a gap no matter how Draconian you elect
to be there's always a gap between the
sudden loss and chasing those chasing
those uh falling revenues down with with
falling costs and that's what's going on
now the the the costs are being cut but
the ramp this is all about how steep
that ramp is going to be with regard to
how how uh what the whether we're going
to be able to use attrition or whether
we're going to require layoffs or
something
the um this is a little I I I'm going to
go through this sort of fast because I'm
I'm not sure what the interest level
would be but with regard to the
benefits the um federal employees and
state employees always have horrible
salaries and good benefits and that's
the case today that's the case today the
it's generally computed at about a
percent you get a percentage of your
high three salary years
and it's based
on so
um the percentage is built on the number
of years you've worked there so you
you'll get about half of your salary
after about a 20y year um career with
the Postal Service I want to get in a
couple more questions because we're
almost over so no I know thank
you hi um there's a historical part to
this question and then a contemporary
part uh so for the historical part um I
think when I uh what I know of the
history of the post office and when I
think of it originally it's this very
radical way of reaching the whole nation
um which has to do with as you mentioned
um you know this then ra radical spread
of newspapers and magazines that
resulted and necessarily as New Media
have come in over time the post office
in some ways has needed to change its
idea of what it was doing and so you
know you once the telegraph enters onto
the scene or broadcast me enter onto the
scene you know the mail is no longer the
only way in which uh information is is
is is being spread and that's there's a
long history of that and um so I guess
um you could argue that there's a bit of
a narrowing of the communication
component of uh the of the male that's
happened over time and so I guess the
first part of my question is from a
historical perspective I mean we've
heard a little bit about the telegraph
but what about other moments like
broadcast media is is it true that you
could car it as a sort of narrowing or
or or what are the patterns in the way
that the mail has been redefined as a
result of the entrance of this New Media
um and then I guess I'll just quickly
say part two of the question is it
almost seems like there are two
different directions that I'm hearing
for the Contemporary options for the
mail and one is this narrowing of you
know collaboration with other businesses
taking advantage of that last
mile aspect of things but that's really
different from thinking about the
infrastructural side um which I don't
know that the last mile component has
much Advantage for that and I almost
feel like I'm hearing two different
visions of we could be going very narrow
or we could be finding a way to go broad
so in the interest of time if each
person could take a minute to address
that and we're going to have to close
post office is important today it was
much more important in our past it was
Wellspring of democracy it was
fundamental to the financing of
political campaigns newspapers magazines
absolutely
indispensable Telegraph came along and
it was not a popular medium until 1910
the president of Western Union will tell
anyone who will listen if you want to
send information over long distances
send a letter don't use Western Union
Revenue annual of Western Union was
never more than onethird of the post
office telegraph was not that important
the post office got a huge boost with uh
corporations but now they're advertising
and that expands magazine and newspaper
uh Revenue and the big changes don't
really occur until relatively recently I
think the spike was still going up uh
certainly you know the 1970s and 1980s
so this is a a new phenomenon but just
to put in a Civic plea it does seem to
me that it would be perfectly in keeping
with the historical Mandate of the post
office to provide special facilities for
print medium or other uh on the neutral
basis other civic-minded uh Publications
maybe even electronic Publications and
that is is very much in keeping with the
Mandate as it was understood by Benjamin
Rush In
David there's a Communications
Revolution going on and Communications
is wildly expanding and increasing so in
some ways All Ships are rising the the
largest year the Postal Service ever had
was just before the economic
downturn um nothing stopped it it always
entangled and mutually
energized and and uh that's been the
story of the Postal Service until this
very these very recent events but the
recent events are
unprecedented so I think that that's
what causes the appearance how you're
you're imagining a zero sum world but
it's not can the communications
Revolution is wildly increasing in an
expotential
fashion and that's what accounts for
that apparent disparaging and the postal
service is a giant Beast there's uh and
it depends on where you look at it you
know it's got a huge front end it's got
a huge middle and a huge Last Mile and
uh the needs of of society determine how
that's all
interconnected what to me is is we've
just begun to see the real it used to be
male versus the internet or male versus
its Alternatives we're just beginning to
see the beginnings of the marriage where
the internet is is connected to the mail
where mail is connected you know through
what we call the intelligent mail
barcodes or Universal product codes or
um you know po you know any number of of
of digital technologies that link the
mail to the internet and make it more
interactive make it more entertaining
make it more relevant and fun and uh
that will determine the future thanks
Ken unfort is it a very quick question
it's a very quick question so we can
only take maybe that's fine okay 20
second but cuz I want to CL I'm a
marketer I send direct mail I have
28,000 pieces in the mail today thank
you what would one do to
help mail more please no what we really
what really matters when what we're
telling the industry what you'd hear at
National postal Forum or the postal
customer council is learn how to mail
smarter that means using less mail where
it's relevant so that it isn't junk I
mean it's the same kind of thing that
you you you hit in the email world you
learn how to be relevant relevant using
the data that you have about your
customers finding out who to mail to at
the appropriate times so it's not junk
mail delivered by snail it's real mail
that helps people make decisions make
helps them do things that are important
to them that would it incre increase
your response rates your Roi it would
make the customer it would increase the
mail moment for the customers and for
the businesses that you're doing
business with and make them happy as
well certainly make our us happy great
well it's exactly 700 p.m. so the goal
was to end on time and I think we've
achieved that I want to thank uh again
all the speakers I want to thank Richard
John Ken Smith and Dave Williams I'd
like to give them a round
ofla